whenever there is a great unjustice
happening a criminal walks free
I dropped my sandwich an animal dies for
no good reason that's when I put my foot
down and I see I get mildly irritated
when these things happen people dying
from War clipping your nails are
slightly too long so it feels weird
these are all mildly irritating things
that makes us go
sometimes that anger just gets too built
up and you need to let it go you need to
move by really letting out a fears I'm
with you 100%
there is just too much injustice in this
world so let's explore it to get them
without the people and see what we can
play
my stress ball just exploded that is
honestly so annoying because then you
gotta clean all that up I think it
happened once one of the stressed boobs
oh yeah it did happen to Ken he asked me
what the f I was taking a picture of I
told him I was taking a pic of the
douchebag that needs talking by two
handicap spots to eat some fries is it
weird that I would do this to say as
well I mean if there's no handicap snake
I'm just saying if there's no handicaps
why did the spot needs to be open I can
clearly just move out of the way listen
there's only one spot when I collect my
mail that is free and it's always just a
handicapped spot where am I supposed to
park this is not my lean fury ating
actually you know what it is earn for
the wrong reason stop discriminating at
people parking at handicapped spot
there's nothing wrong with it there's a
stigma spend hours completing this
mildly infuriating puzzle and now I can
yeah I guess that's mildly infuriating
what do you want me to say this is
pathetic
this is all that you have to bother your
life and take one step in my shoes and
you would feel real pain
you would feel real my lead in whatever
five bananas well maybe one of the
bananas isn't a banana have you thought
about that before judging your anger
maybe you should think critically like
me before you yet let your emotions pity
thoughts rule over your mind and body I
haven't agreed with a single one so far
I thought this would be my these pencils
suck then don't buy them what the hell
is and all these crybabies Jesus Christ
this dad mailed a container of sliced
mangoes to his daughter in college
[Music]
this is not interesting make me so angry
stupid daughter I don't care about your
sliced mangoes there's more important
information that I could fill up my mind
with serpent but father and mango I
don't care I don't care about this
article from BuzzFeed having screenshots
saved in a screenshot does that actually
happen that is some fury okay I'm not
gonna read this post people who wore out
sis punch people who wore out
unsuspecting relatives for virtual
numbers my daughter does not think I can
get 98 likes for being 98 years old can
we prove her a lot wrong please share
one like equals respect how about
something interesting
these pity anything just is these kids
just think anything deserves likes these
days how about 98 likes to kill your
grandad
then I will like it then it would be
interesting don't waste my time
Gillette no sells four pack of blades
instead of five packs still the same
price and even the same packaging the
only thing fury ating about this is that
Dollar Shave Club won't sponsor me what
is up with that ah no rush you got lots
of time Oh what is this I was hoping I
could wait 60 more seconds that's so
annoying
Quaker Oatmeal advertises 35% less sugar
but in reality they're just selling 35%
smaller portions lower sugar Wow that's
brilliant
I hate ups just a little bit more every
day I'm working from home down stairs
and I'm hard of hearing please ring the
doorbell or yell I'm here thank you
sorry we missed you yeah I they love
handing out these goddamn things I don't
even want the package this is why I park
at the handicap spot at the post office
I need my revenge oh I know something
that really irritates commenters if I
have my headphones not balanced what
y'all mad about today Professor X could
move anything with his mind so why not
his f king this is what I'm talking
about the handicapped spot you know
what's actually mildly infuriating about
this it's the amount of time people
spend talking about comic book heroes
and why would that doesn't make any
sense
god I just realized that Professor X
can't have sex it never occurred to me
that his d doesn't work either F man I'm
surprised he's such a positive guy
nobody had sex in years
well now I'm just sad I'm not infuriated
you know what that is infuriating this
guy has been talking on the phone for 10
minutes with this flashlight on just
tell him excuse me sir your flashlight
is on you are burning more battery and
blinding other people is that so hard
instead you just take an Alford photo to
upload and ready pathetic I'm for the
wrong reason which makes me even more
let me try to say
class of 2015 to zero
poor congratulations the American school
system you have outdone yourself yet
again but that's my dad's middle name
what is your father's middle name Paul
enter an answer that is at least five
characters clearly his name is not Paul
it's something else
clearly your dad is lying to you
sorry that was a bit much I am I do
apologize I was staring at it all flight
oh she's wearing she's wearing the right
headphones in the last it's another
thing huh I had if I have my headphones
not balanced as well it's all people
comment about in the comment section
thinking they're like so so quirky about
their OCD when you really you're just a
bunch of crybabies do you have such a
perfect life that this literally mild
inconveniences this is bothering you
this is bothering you in my ball I'm
sorry am i bothering you right now am i
bothering you maybe she was facing the
seat the whole time why can't they
design their cables better and it's just
so annoying stop buying Apple products
you dummies do you think it's impossible
to make them more sturdy and better you
think they're not just trying to make
you buy new cables you think there's a
reason because if you plug in other
off-brand ones Apple won't even approve
them
you have to buy their own ones stop
buying Apple products and then I'll buy
into your stuff crying this this whole
video is just me getting hankering for
the complete wrong reason being stuck
behind this for miles just go around
they said there's this you can nearly
just go around what's the problem Oh
like you know both are their speeds if
one is going
half a mile per hour quicker then it
shouldn't take miles for you to wait get
there wouldn't it you dum-dum scum bum
booty but I watch two for tonight what
you don't want to watch colorful videos
for kids what youtube this makes me
actually this lady watching a beach
wedding they put up a yellow police tape
all around the beach yet somehow this
random lady in the blue swimsuit still
fascinated
someone needs to shoot that that woman
this is why I'm for the Second Amendment
why why do I need an account just to
look at Pinterest this is by far the
highest one why are people using
Pinterest then that's my real question
yeah you search for Google Images you
get a Pintrest result oh ok apparently I
won't view this picture sukkah yeah this
better be good the most tense 13 days of
the Cold War occurred during the event
known as stiff Cuban Missile Crisis
wrong correct answer Cuban Missile
Crisis selca yeah
speaking of cyka guys this is the last
chance you'll get to buy this merch
check out represent calm slash PewDiePie
and become a real black today very nice
very nice-nice chance guys
thank you everyone that bought it so far
really appreciate it thank you for
watching this video and let me know
leave a like if you're and leave a
double like if you didn't
and I'll see you guys in the next video
goodbye